c'est ici que tout a commencé dans cette
maison familiale chargée de souvenirs là
où les deux frères se raconte et déjà
des histoires quand il était petit là où
les paysages laisse place à l'évasion et
à l'inspiration on est dans la ferme
familiale où on a grandi avec jean
françois et c'est vrai que la passion de
l'écriture elle est venue assez tôt chez
nous et forcément quand on grandit dans
un lieu inspirant comme ça avec une
légende autour du lac au fait avec un
paysage un peu bucolique
bah ça donne des idées et puis après ça
donne envie de mettre sur le papier la
maison d'édition le lac aux faits est
spécialisée dans l'imaginaire avec pour
le moment deux thèmes fantasy et
fantastique et une marque de fabrication
des couvertures destinées de ce qu'on
voulait c'est de très belles couvertures
pour que les lecteurs puissent
s'identifier et donc par exemple pour un
temps sa tôt on voulait une couverture
qui qu'ils puissent y invite le lecteur
à rentrer dans l'univers du livre à
l'origine jean françois et céréaliers
mais pour lui entre ces chants et son
écriture il n'y a qu'un pas j'écris
souvent le week-end et les formes les
règles avantageant tant qu'agriculteur
qu'on est dans ce tracteur brrr on peut
on peut en venir réfléchir à nos idées
avec énormément de l'histoire qui sont
et qui ont qui sont nés en fin de compte
dans dans les champs on va dire au
contact de la nature avec la nature
m'inspire beaucoup
pas facile de se lancer pendant le
confine on est en pleine crise de
coronavirus mais les deux frères
souhaite permettre aux lecteurs de
s'évader pour ensuite être rejoint à
moyen terme par d'autres auteurs qui
partagent leur univers